Hi and welcome back to unit4 of CS215.
We call this unit putting things in order or who is your 17th best friend.
So, by now, you might not be surprised that I actually have a magic trick worked out
that is, actually, in this case relevant to the topic at hand.
So, in this magic trick, I'm going to put a bunch of animals in order with your help.
So, here's some data, I have it stored as a Python structure at the moment.
We caught animals--it has 11 animals in it, alphabetized dog to sparrow,
and I've gone on the Internet and looked up the speed, how fast each of these animals is;
it's weight, approximately in kg;
Life span, how long they tend to live, and how big their brains are, measured in g.
I did not go and measured these animals' brains.
So, pretty common operation in social network analysis and lots of other problems
is to be able to put items in order.
So, in this particular case, we have a bunch of animals, we like to put them in order,
but there's lots of different dimensions on which to order them.
What we're going to do is we're going look at a linear combination of these numeric features,
and you're going to pick from me the weight, the positive weights,
to put on each of these different attributes and then we're going to take a sum,
in fact, I got the code right here for you to look at.
What I'd like you to do is run this code on this data and what you do is you call importance rank
on this data set animals and you give it the weights.
I gave a weight of 1 for the speed, 0.4 for the weight,
2 for the life span, and 0.1 for the brain mass.
So, if you would run it with this weights, it would actually compute a score for each of the animals
and then print them out in sorted order, but I want you to give your own weight.
Don't use mine because that wouldn't be very tricky with it.
Any weight you want just as long as they are not negative or zero.
But the program is going to print out are the numbers 0 through 10 for the 11 different animals
and I want you to make a note of, I don't know, let's say the fourth highest in the list,
the one that's associated with the number 3,
and I want you to make note of which animal appears in this position
and mark the corresponding circle.
And what makes this as a magic trick is that the algorithm that I'm using, the running time is so fast,
that it's θ(-n), that is to say I can compute the answer to this question
before you've asked the question--so, I've already run this.
I know what answer you're going to get, but now, you need to run it to make it so
and let's see if you're right.